allison janney gives an update on mom  co-star on a ferris she has so much love  [Music]  he spoke with the actress at the  premiere of her new film I Tania during  the Toronto International Film Festival  on Saturday where she opened up about  Ferris who recently split from husband  Chris Pratt after eight years of  marriage  your good friend Anna Faris named you as  one of her close confidants and just  wondering how she's doing this day she  has so much love and support on the set  of mom she's a very courageous strong  girl and very professional and and who  love her so much as to everyone and we  love Chris - we left them both and it's  it's sad when you know people you love  have to go separate ways but we support  them both and love them both very much  [Music]